I really don't think that there's anything that society loves more
than putting a girl or a woman way up on the highest tippity pedestal,
only to, like,
gather around and watch and cheer as we tear her right off of it.
we're not out here requiring male celebrities to endorse candidates
and endorse the candidate that we want them to
and articulate why they're endorsing that candidate
in a way that pleases us.
They're allowed to just do the bare minimum and focus on their art.
And a good amount of times they can't even do that.
They'll be like, blatantly horrible.
And in those situations, society will be like,
well, I'm separating the art from the artist.
I am hearing more commentary about what Chapel Ron,
a 26 year old girl if what she is and isn't doing correctly,
then I have heard about the actual atrocities that P.
Diddy inflicted on a ton of people's lives with the help of others,
and he's like a grown ass man who did it deliberately.
And I'm sure that there's commentary that's valid.
All I'm saying is there's a clear double standard
of how much we expect out of young women and girls
and how much we love to tear them down
in a way that we don't do with male celebrities.